if you're thinking about getting into
business and you're not sure where to
start the business you get into is not
going to be the one you end up with
there's this idea that you need to have
the perfect pick the fallacy of the
perfect pick for a new entrepreneur and
that's why they get so obsessive of
bouncing between thing and thing because
they think the thing is the thing that
matters but it's them that matters like
if I start a la care company I can get
it to a bil I can do that if you do
stick with whatever you do on a long
enough time rise it and take feedback
and improve it's very tough to beat if
you keep improving 10% 20% a year 20%
over 12 years is 10x and so if you're
like I'm making a million you're at 10
million but then thing if you do that
again you're a sense a millionaire